yeah yeah oh you know what city I don't
like at all is Hiroshima
is it tied with Nagasaki it's close
[Music]
hey you know be honest we're off the
records hey uh we're off of the record
let loose okay I won't what are some
cities you hate and why cities yeah
whole cities you got good prompts man
why do you hate these things full cities
whole cities oh and Sonata you hate
incidents I agree you could bomb
Ensenada I'll be fine what bomb that
place because it's a tourist hellhole
yeah like like Hollywood Highlander and
Rosarito bomb both of them
I can understand that now but man in
college that [__] was so fun you know
what I don't like about Ensenada though
it's the [__] constant Hawking yeah
that's what I mean
it was kind of like that in um playo Del
Carmen it was a little bit like that but
the Ensenada is just on crack dude I
just left puertoverte it was [__]
Thai so nobody was hounding you no not
one time it was sick but yeah Ensenada
is like it's like being on Hollywood
Highland which I hate already I'd never
want to go there I only had to go there
for work stuff like if I was trolling or
whatever like other than that I don't
want to be there yeah but it's the same
idea it's the same exact place it looks
the same same everything same like come
get a tour of like something [__] that
you don't want to see and like oh cool
maybe I'll see that wow that's you know
[__] Michelle Pfeiffer's house you're
like okay
I'm like like Hollywood Highland right
so they shot
they shot this dealer there kind of like
for 30 seconds yeah it's like that what
is there to do in Ensenada like nothing
it's this that's what it's Anonymous
you go over after a cruise
you buy [__] weird non-stick like
churros
um you get conned into going up to like
some third [__] story restaurant and
they [__] poor tequila in your mouth
you have to pay for everything you get
to like pet a tiger and [__] but then
the Tiger's drugged no really it's it's
just oh they got zebras walking around
but really they're just donkeys painted
like zebras
he's bound down they grab Nikki and my
friend jessal Zama so I'm there I'm
there with like her husband at the time
right he's my boy and then we're there
and you guys met jessal Zama and then so
like they just grabbed Nikki and Jess
and they just start marching them
through like blowing whistles and [__]
and then me and my buddy Joe we're like
chasing our chicks down and then like
they're like grabbing Nikki's shorts and
like opening them up and like pouring a
navel shot for me to take and then yeah
exactly like that like now you guys got
to pay for everything it's like [__]
hey this is crazy wow that's not against
you that's how they get you I saw they
get the Commerce over there yeah with
your outfit though I would totally grab
you and your wife and baby he looks like
a good tourist smart you look like a
good Mark I could Pat I could picture
him with the glasses every new year that
has the the the sign the 20th to 2023
yeah yeah two two yeah I wouldn't I
wouldn't grab [__] a Mark I know he's
not paying for [__]
I'm not that much of a mark after all
yo that's on you any other cities you
guys don't like Beijing oh why I buried
everybody in Beijing
maybe not Beijing now but Beijing 2006
it was so there was so many con artists
and pickpockets and like it was just a
poor country than what it is today and
so like you can't when you're when
you're just like looking over your
shoulder and the type of people I was
with they weren't street smart and I was
just relying on them to take me
everywhere and we were getting [__]
jacked and conned left and right and I
was sitting there like [__] man what the
[__] like yeah it was it was it may be
like not the city but just the things
that happened
because there were great times that
happened too your experience dictates
your per yeah bury the city there were
great time to vote it was the best it
was the one what about like it is it is
super crowded there yeah when I went it
was winter so it was around New Year we
did we spent New Year's in Hong Kong and
then January 2nd we went to so this was
2005 2006. we went to uh Beijing that's
where you went wrong it was went from
Hong Kong to Beijing oh why is that
wrong no it's because they're both like
for a foreigner for a tourist they're
both Chinese but they are completely
different you know what I mean like for
example uh
weather especially he's talking about
January time you know the weather and
then two it's like food food is way
different Hong Kong Foods against
opinion but it felt like Mother Russia
you know what I mean where what about
the general behavior of people there's
Hong Kong people everybody in Hong Kong
speaks English yeah but Hong Kong people
were meaner I thought oh wow because
they knew you were Japanese
they could smell it yeah
[Music]
mind you this is 2006. the way that
Beijing looked at the time was it looked
apocalyptic because all the buildings
were half built so like everything like
skyscrapers were just all like some of
it looked empty and and built like it
was just weird and then there were all
these massive roads with like three cars
or like a guy with a [__] donkey car
like so then and then it's definitely
not Beijing now that's what I'm saying
is like back then it was a bit it looked
poor and then so like
how dare you look poor because now when
I see pictures of Beijing that's not
what I saw more Rich it's like it's like
bustling with people and cars and
whatever but back then it felt like it
felt like a former Soviet like Wasteland
area because the security guards too
they would wear the red star in their
like like warm fuzzy hats in the
uniforms and stuff and then so you would
see like
like like dudes do like 15 hour shifts
like I would I would come into the hotel
like six in the morning we're like
playing sleeping whatever we go out it's
the same door man for like I'm like he
was there like earlier wait when does
that guy sleep that's because they're
allowed to sleep out their post they
also look alike
you know what city I don't like but uh
this is definitely a hot tape because I
know a lot of people who like live here
who would not be happy I said Los
Angeles [__] Bakersfield Long Beach
I got family there I was just there for
Christmas Long Beach is pretty sick I
actually enjoy Long Beach as a city but
I've been pulled over by cops there like
four times okay oh yeah because you're
parking in handicap spots no no no
that's Glendale oh yeah yeah Glendale is
a stickler bro but straight up dude like
[__] the way that cops just treated
me up they're just mean to you and four
times too you just you just build a
relationship with the city being pulled
over a bunch of sucks yeah in one city
why do they pull you over like how would
they treat you stupid [__] like I was
like breaking law like whatever regular
stuff that's like speed how's it going
85 into 15. oh Justified whatever pass a
crossing guard get away with it in other
cities it's a smooth ride I didn't know
it was not that fast I wanted to go to
Long Beach so much there's always a lot
of dance events there the convention
center yeah oh oh you know what city I
don't like at all it's Hiroshima
is it tied with Nagasaki it's close wait
why Hiroshima well they just wouldn't
stay down
geez stupid
always pissed me off
so it's slightly different reason for
Ensenada no honestly Germany bro the
whole country Germany I'm from there too
apparently like ancestry whatever the
[__] partially but no I when I was there
was creepy but I was there in the middle
of winter but it's [__] creepy yeah
yeah it is the thickness like the
building style
um is it the war crimes and stuff
yeah Berlin No we're the I was actually
staying at this hotel that had like the
biggest aquarium in the world River this
[__] Radisson blue it just blew up oh
yeah oh that was that place yeah because
of the one in the middle yeah because
they had this thing about Heating in the
winter and so they they made them turn
off the heat in the lobby and then this
[__] giant aquarium like the biggest
[__] oh the biggest aquarium ever that
one yeah yeah me and Nikki stayed there
and I met my brother Nate there well she
met my brother Nate there um he was in
the military at the time and then yeah
that thing blew up and then all these
dead fish all over the [__] place it
was crazy but yeah there's is a
heaviness thickness in that City very
odd I was in Munich and it's such a like
Germany is a different country compared
to all the every everywhere else has
like I feel like a little bit of
flamboyant or like like flared to their
buildings colorful yeah like Italy or
like well I've never been there but just
the look of like France and there's just
some color when you're in Germany their
buildings are just like structured great
big stone structures that's kind of cold
out there or some gargoyles yeah it
looks like weird like dark and I went to
this place called the reichstag which is
supposed to be a museum and I was like
this is a bummer
[Laughter]
Anne Frank's house or something
swag
not even nothing like the book he's like
what is this where's the [__] Modern
Art I do enjoy Germany's uh uh only
maybe only Germans will get the schlaga
culture it's like they're um I was
choreographing for this like uh uh this
pop star out there named Helena Fisher
she's basically like their their number
one [__] German pop star thing right
careful we still got a Hasselhoff around
yeah no matter what song every [__]
concert was sold out and no matter what
song she was saying if if all the
audience members if all of them can go
like this the whole time it's a good
song If you can't do that during the
song it's like a ballad or something
like that you're kind of like I know
what that looks like you can't hold your
beard during Oktoberfest and do this you
know what I mean but when yeah but when
you everybody can do this you're like
this is kind of fun this is kind of
tired and then that's why you understand
things like Oktoberfest or the boot or
whatever you know you have the [__]
water I mean the beard just spilling
everywhere and you just doing this this
kind of tie honestly I would have buried
London too but I had a great experience
recently so my neighbor he's like this
poker King and [__] but he's like a Brit
and we I was watching the world cup with
him and they were you know it was it was
the UK versus like Paris or France yeah
France and I went to this place in Vegas
that was like a British pub and it was
like every Brit in Vegas was there and
and I had this moment with him where we
were getting beers in the bar and he's
like so packed like you couldn't even I
couldn't even move my arms at all but
the we're holding beers and we're
watching the screen and uh they score
like the UK scores and I have never been
around anything more electric like in a
long time like everyone in the whole bar
exploded I got a beer bath like get
[__] getting dressed and beer and
[__] and nobody cares I didn't care
especially UK versus France yeah that's
a big one dude and I used to hate soccer
so much that was so boring but that like
woke me up to a little bit I was like oh
man being around the fans like the
people who [__] love this [__] I was
like all right I get this sport a little
bit more so did you know that out there
you're born into the team you're not you
don't choose teams so like wherever your
parents are from or like because you
know how like it's generational or like
if you're like if you're from a city
like Liverpool or whatever right like
that's your team World Cup wise yeah
yeah or like World Cup I think is in it
connected you're talking about like
football club regions like you're part
of the football club against [__] yeah
that's just kind of time it's fun you
know it's you know it's a pretty wax
City that whenever I explain to other
people and people from this country they
agree uh Blackpool
where's that Blackpool England really
why is it so whack sounds like a cool
name starting with the people wise it's
sort of like a holiday place to go
that's sort of like the budget choice I
think it's like a lot you'll see a lot
of stag parties you see a lot of you
know those like when you go to another
country and you see a group of British
guys and they're super Rowdy and they're
stalking each other and they're vulgar
and and just like the worst it's all of
them together
so like everywhere you go so it's like
Tampa Bay yeah you're just running into
a bunch of those guys Phil it's like
Philly and it's kind of like a sad
looking like it kind of just looks like
a decrepit like if California Adventure
was abandoned for 700 years
yeah it just looks very cool so not
spare Farm yeah true just less funnel
cake less Jam yeah it we went there for
a dance competition like in the early
quest days and here's a funny story
actually we went there with um it was a
competition and the only two American
teams was Quest Crew and jabbawockies
and this is before either of us was on
TV or anything and then we went out
there they lost Java's luggage on the
flight or whatever we were like a tiny
um there was like a the regular division
which is like crew versus whatever
showcase none of us won but then they
were like hey you know there's a battle
where teams can battle other teams and
then us and Jabba combined would make up
the required number you needed to do it
that big yeah it was like 15 or
something so we're like yo let's link up
and smoke everybody and we immediately
lost
really good to what crew no a no-name
like British crew because was it rick
are they good it's not rigged we didn't
understand the rules so like people had
known for I guess like months what the
music was gonna be they prepared all
these like routines and all these things
and it was like You Got Served live like
they had prep so they had routines to
their music yeah yeah exactly so they
had people had pieces and then we went
out blind thinking we could just like
battling and it just wasn't scoring the
criteria so they were like you guys
aren't doing any of the like you're just
being doing backflips out yeah yeah
exactly
cocky American like I went out by myself
I took a whole like two minutes killed
it and they're like that's not you're
not supposed to do that it sucks and we
hated it oh that's so cocky I love it
jabbered Quest together the only time we
had the lights we lost instantly and
then it's back to warland in Blackpool
battle time Blackpool England that's
[__] hilarious Ryan's like I [__]
hate this scene yeah
criteria is stupid when Jabba loses her
luggage is it like all masks they had to
go buy new masks yeah new Gilligan hats
did you look in hats in math am I wrong
is that crazy
um they're called kangels but that's
very funny I don't know what else to
call they're called kangels Gilligan
hats so do you hate Norwalk or something
me no
I don't know if there's a city I
actually hate
Detroit why do you say Norwalk I don't
know just naming some random
of all people you don't want to be
controversial about a whole city
you don't want to slander a Commerce I'm
not a fan of like Ethan Allen or
whatever well we know that whole cities
dude I can't think of a city that I
don't like either like like Glendale or
something what's Pasadena's rival San
Marino no does anyone like Glendale by
the way I kind of like Glendale I like
Barry blender I just don't like
Armenians
that's why I like Glendale my dad was
born that whole area got so much better
by the mo by the Americana that whole
area they're trying to turn that into
the Grove oh the American is incredible
that whole area got so cool because like
any City with hills I love and then you
got all that dope [__] over there you
like movie theater [__] stores and
stuff everything you got everything you
need yeah it was a dope City they just
got some dumbass cut cops what's with
that I've always I don't know I just
like Hill I like cities with hills it
just feels like there's like movement so
I like the landscape yeah so like
Diamond bar or Apollo Verdes I've always
just liked cities that have Hills Chino
Hills yeah like even like Monterey Park
compared to Alhambra I like Monterey
Park more than Alhambra because Alhambra
is just flat and the Monterey Park has
Hills yeah yeah yeah I just always liked
Hills so anywhere with hills good dude
likes Hills anywhere no Hills you
[__] suck
all right bro you could die
you can't live in
Florida it's a valley below those places
up make Hills yeah
I guess yeah we're in like Orlando once
you go on like just like the fourth
floor you can see to the Horizon because
everything is [__] flat yeah I also
did it like Atlanta really only because
it's and it's not it's unfair to the
city but like I that's the most racism I
ever experienced like like Atlanta like
Point Blank roasting like you're just
walking in the mall and then dudes are
just like yo what the [__] look at this
pool like like that like they've never
seen a Filipino before I think it's just
because we were just a group of Asians
like I we're asking for it a little bit
because that's Quest Crew in that year
we would stand out a little like because
of our [__] because you're
coordinating all the purple and oh the
anime here yeah just how we looked it
was just like out here it's [__]
normal but like there it's and you're
walking you're just I think with that
type of like rougher groups you're gonna
you're asking for it a little bit Yeah
so they would just like rip on and they
would rip on Hawk hella bad they'd be
like what the [__] is he Native American
okay
but just so vocal and out and like like
as if we're being heckled on stage yeah
and we're just trying to go to a
freaking you know Urban Outfitters
there's a Native American but he sounds
like he wants to order fish and chips
and it would happen like it would happen
a lot so we're like dude this place
sucks man
Atlanta the land of relics I've never
been to Atlanta I've never been there
I've been to San Antonio San Antonio
it's like I don't think I because every
time I go to certain cities it's like
I'm there for a couple of days like I
went there specifically to coach someone
to fight and we were there for like a
couple days and then we just leave and
we get like the worst of it so it's like
it's hard for me to really like give it
a good shot like oh we got to do this
like we just stayed on the Riverwalk and
Riverwalk sick yeah it was cool it was
cool but then like it was just it was
like neutral some guy called me a
[__] I told that story I like that
part I was like what dude I started
laughing yeah yeah but other than that
it was like it's all good dude damn did
you meet a [__] night like 18 20
[__] gold miner or something hey
remember
he met a 49er and [__] we were we were
walking on the Riverwalk and it was one
of those restaurants where they talk
[__] to you okay and like he was trying
to Hawk us to get inside the restaurant
oh yeah then he like got shot yeah
because he said something about like oh
hey see the guy was like oh I like your
shorts and he said that to I thought he
was saying it to my friend and I was
like oh he likes your shorts and he goes
no I'm talking to you [__] and I
look over and he goes uh he's like he
immediately like took it back he was
like ah I just started laughing and I
looked at my homie and I was like yo he
called me a shot of it have you seen
your ears and he's like oh [__] he knows
bro I was like 115 pounds too like it
don't matter that's where I'm kind of
glad like being Filipino you don't they
don't know what the term is I've been
called like every other Asian slur yeah
but there's just what's your favorite
one they call you I've been called
Google
growing up I got called [__] by Mexicans
a lot oh really you don't even look you
look more Mexican than me it's just it's
not it's not how I look it's the limited
knowledge they have on how they don't
know what to say yeah they can't profile
this guy they just don't know how to
hurt my feelings so they're just like
say yo what the [__] is pretty crazy
because I don't even know what the [__]
that's one of the craziest ones I've
ever heard yeah like he just blew their
brains yeah there are some funny roasts
but like like once I'm like walking
around like these dudes were like oh
[__] yo are you about to break out blue
eyes white dragon because it look like
Yu-Gi-Oh because my hair was like spiky
[__] like if it's if it's funny then um
did you go to the same high school as I
did no that wouldn't happen in high
school that's what it sounds like it
happened in Atlanta yeah yeah yeah those
guys went to my high school did you see
that guy the fighter who came out
dressed as Sapphire Roth recently
sephiroth really what I thought you
would like that why would that I don't
know some fighter came out dressed like
sephiro please tell me he was like black
or something though I don't know that
would be tight yeah that's what I'm
saying like a black stuff broth what he
comes out with the [__] long hair wig
too before he takes off and fights I
immediately thought of you though I was
like usually it's like cities you hate
is mainly the experience you had there
but
in terms of like actual like
municipalities I don't think I hate any
City other than Blackpool no black
people
San Diego kind of sucks yeah yeah you
think it sucks you're gonna have
beautiful places do you think it's
because it's kind of sleepy you get
sleepy it's retirementy yeah it's like
yeah if you're 65 it's great yeah
Escondido yeah [__] Escondido San Diego
I live there you did yeah I lived there
you think it's the best weather in all
of America it's the most boring
easily so blue sky every day Blue Sky
every day I think they got a really
great Mexican food they have really good
fish tacos they do but [__] Escondido
who said that [__] Escondido he did he
did he did I lived there dude that's
where I lived and you didn't like it
it's [__] Tom I don't even know
where that is
near San Diego it's the hottest part of
San Diego probably easily is it more
Inland well it's like up it's like
normal geez just because they don't have
a Gaslamp district well The Gaslight
District sucks too I had to go there for
a buddy's um bachelor party one time and
like oh my God the misery I do think a
bachelor party in gas lineup is pretty
weak it's weak bro exactly and no but
the best part oh you're by the zoo you
the BET oh yeah exactly now the best
part was that the the best man put
together the idea right so we'll go to
the Gas Lamp we'll like you know do a
beer crawl or some [__] right but then
the best man lived in San Diego so he
didn't have to [__] pay to go
anywhere he's got to hang out there so
then the poor groom had to [__] deal
with this [__] we could have gone to
Vegas by the way but no that's just
pushing the logistics onto someone else
exactly you know you went you and
um Nikki both come from uh a little bit
of uh like not Central Coast culture but
like off of a major city but California
like Coast culture yeah well I'm from
all over but she definitely is from
Santa Barbara or Beach culture
escondido's a little I got like affected
as a child by like weather and seasons
and [__] so when I moved out here it was
very bitter that I didn't have anymore
so I [__] always hated California
because they're like where's that now
yeah I missed like weather Seasons
nothing ever felt real even Christmas
day didn't feel real for me for like 20
years so yeah coming from that I could
totally see that yeah yeah you're just
being robbed basically yeah
California dude it does it's like blue
skies and it's like 80. it was 80
degrees this year during Christmas yeah
it was the hottest day of December it
was on Christmas I mean you guys could
go to Big Bear take that back dude I
Like Big Bear besting fun you gotta
drive forever dude yeah forever enjoy
the fire and then you gotta drive back
it's only an hour for us this is like
kind of like a great conversation for us
but like maybe kind of a boring video
for people it's just who come on man
take that back take that [__] back man
hey look at that bag we'll see if he's
right
[Music]